president trump prepares for the state
of the union address stacy abrams
prepares for her response and virginia
democrats continue their slow motion
implosion
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
man who is excited for the state of the
union address tonight
yeah yeah you can sense that excitement
out there i'm so excited i'm going to go
in the back and hang myself later
i am very pumped up about this but i'll
do it after we have our state of the
union
address coverage tonight because i know
that we all have to suffer through that
together i was so excited about the
government shutdown we'll get to
all of this in just one second first
let's talk let's talk about how you can
send your packages more cheaply so
postage rates have gone up again
thankfully stamps.com can ease the pain
with big discounts off post office
retail rates with stamps.com you save
five cents off every first class stamp
off
and up to 40 off priority mail that kind
of savings really does add up especially
for small businesses
plus stamps.com is completely online
which saves you time no more
inconvenient trips to the post office
stamps.com automatically calculates and
prints the exact amount of postage you
need for every letter or package you
send you're never going to overpay or
underpay again
stamps.com brings all the services of
the us postal service directly to your
fingertips this means that you can buy
and print
official us postage on any letter any
piece of mail you print it right onto
the envelope or you print it onto a
piece of paper and tape it to the
envelope or you print it onto a sticker
stamps.com makes it super easy they even
send you a free
digital scale which automatically
calculates exact postage for you that's
why we use stamps.com here at the daily
wire offices to save ourselves time and
money right now
our listeners get a special offer it
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale
see for yourself why over seven hundred
thousand small businesses use stamps.com
stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in promo code
shapiro for the special deal that is
stamps.com promo code shapiro once again
stamps.com
promo code shapiro so i have to tell you
a little bit of behind the scenes here
at the ben shapiro show
it's not an auspicious day for the state
of the union here at the ben shapiro
show because
it's raining in los angeles first of all
and whenever it rains in los
angeles people around the area believe
that god's wrath has fallen
upon this town at long last second of
all our normal studios you may have
noticed that if you watch the show
that our normal studios you know the
bright beautiful lights have been
replaced by this deep dank cell
you know this terrible terrible place
that resembles the pit of despair from
the princess bride
well it turns out that not only have we
moved into a temporary studio
while we build out our beautiful new
magnificent studios but also there are
huge leaks in here that happen every
time it rains
so as we prepare for the state of the
union address we are also smelling the
decomposing corpses
of people that our producer senia
murdered earlier and then stacked up
behind the curtains behind all the
soundstage boards and everything
so you know it's a little depressing to
be contemplating your own mortality
while smelling the mold coming off the
corpses as you prepare for the state of
the union address so that's that's my
mood this morning
as i prepared for the state of the union
address president trump of course is
supposed to give the state of the union
address tonight at long last
the government shutdown did have its
good aspects one of those aspects was no
state of the union address now i know
there are some people who get super
pumped up about the state of the union
they love the pomp
they love the circumstance they are into
it man they are just
excited as can be about the state of the
union address they cannot wait for
president trump to go out there and say
a bunch of words that no one's going to
remember five minutes after he said them
quick quiz do you remember anything from
president trump's state of the union
address last year
i do but only because i do this
professionally i remember a couple of
things one there was the north korean
guy who's picking up his crutches
and second there was the the soldier's
wife
who he paid tribute to while some
democrats stood for a second and then
sat down right but those
were both controversial i don't remember
a single thing that he said
i remember the the people that he used
for the for the props because this is
what we've been doing since ronald
reagan
where the president points up into the
raptures and he goes and now let me tell
you the story
of bob and then everyone points to bob
and he's like yeah bob woo
so we're going to get a lot of that
tonight and that's why we treat this
thing
like it is a an entertainment vehicle
and one of the big questions is who's
going to bring
whom as guests who's got which guests
are going to show up
so here are the people who president
trump is bringing for his guests at the
state of the union
at the capitol building tomorrow the
guests are going to include deborah
bissell heather armstrong and madison
armstrong these are family members of
gerald and sharon david who were killed
by an illegal immigrant
so president trump i'm sure is going to
talk about illegal immigrant crime and
how it's linked to his need for a border
wall obviously
i have recommended that what president
trump actually should do is
literally take a paragraph from bill
clinton's state of the union address in
1993 and just read it straight
and let the media go nuts over how
extreme it is and then release a video
of him
side by side with bill clinton saying
the exact same words on his twitter feed
the other folks matthew charles was
released from prison under the first
step back that's criminal justice reform
grace elin a 10 year old cancer survivor
judah samet who's a member of the tree
of life synagogue in pittsburgh who
survived the horrific shooting
and tom whiberly the father of a navy
seaman killed in a terrorist attack
all worthy people one of the names on
the list is joshua trump
who is joshua trump is he any relation
to trump no he has no relation to
president trump
he is a sixth grader who the white house
explains has been bullied in school
due to his last name so a couple of
months ago there was a big story about
him
here's what it said the bullying started
two years ago when he was at clemont
elementary school according to his
principal
that was about the time donald j trump
became president joshua's family might
change his last name from trump which he
got from his mother megan from tuberto
his father's last name all that to stop
schoolyard teasing he said i had to sit
down with my son and hear him tell me
that he hates himself and that he feels
sad all the time his mom said
on facebook so a couple of things that
are that are sort of odd about this
first of all i'm not denying
in any way that this kid got bullied
obviously i mean
if you are bullied i mean i was
viciously bullied in school bullying is
awful
and people who are bullies are pieces of
human debris
with that said is the single best
example of bullying across the country
somebody who shares the president's last
name
like there's something peculiarly
self-serving about
i'm going to talk i'm going to talk
about bullying and you know who's really
bullied people with the last name
trump those people oh my goodness
i had suggested earlier that it would be
kind of hilarious if president trump
went
and the person who's been bullied the
most the person who's been believed the
most
is that man ronald trump and then he
just points up into the balcony
and it's a picture of donald trump with
a mustache
again this whole event you may sense
that i'm making light of the state of
the union address
that's because i think it's incredibly
stupid the state of the union address
was meant to be a letter sent by the
president to congress saying
what's going on and now it's this big
monarchical display where the president
comes in and we all cheer yeah because
the executive branch is so
important even though it was supposed to
be the second most important branch
after the
legislative branch and then we have
members of the supreme court who sit
there and they clap and then they sit
there silently while the president
insults them
so barack obama did to members of the
supreme court so it'll just be it'll
just be a good time so who else is
president trump bringing he's bringing
ashley evans who has struggled with
opioid and substance abuse for much of
her life in 2017 she was pregnant and
suffered a relapse
her recovery began with the birth of her
daughter along with the help of
bridget's path medical care facility in
kettering
ohio so that's one of the guests elvin
hernandez a special agent with
trafficking in persons unit of the
department of homeland security
roy james who's plant manager of the
vicksburg forest products lumber
facility
so i guess that his vicksburg was
designated in an opportunity zone so
he's going to talk about the the tax act
you know it'll be it'll be
a lot of people it'll be a lot of people
just be like a whole group of folks
alice johnson is showing up of course
alice johnson was
the woman who was released thanks to the
intervention of
kim kardashian so that'll be exciting
meanwhile the democrats are preparing
their response to the state of the union
address and the person who they have
chosen to give this state of the union
response is stacy abrams now stacey
abrams will recall
narrowly lost her gubernatorial race in
georgia she did very well in the suburbs
stacey abrams one of the reasons she did
well in the suburbs when she ran for
governor of georgia
is because her sort of radical
intersectional message is not what she
spat out in in the georgia suburbs in
the georgia suburbs she talked about
sort of a moderate plan for keeping
people safe
and some new government programs but she
did not campaign as sort of a hardcore
intersectional
pander to the democratic-based candidate
that is exactly what she has become
after this race was over she started
number one complaining that the election
was not legitimate
she still refuses to acknowledge that
she lost that race and then
she started talking in pure
intersectional terms about why we should
divide each other by identity group and
she has a long piece in foreign affairs
magazine a very long piece in foreign
affairs magazine
in which she talks about how upset she
is with francis fukuyama francis
fukuyama the end of history guy from the
1990s who suggested that liberal
capitalism
had won the world and therefore the end
of history may have arrived well he
wrote a piece recently in which he
decried identity politics as tribalism
and he talked about the tribal nature of
our politics and why it's supremely
dangerous well stacey abrams wrote a
response in which she said she's a fan
of tribal politics
she thinks that intersectionality which
is basically the theory that we can all
be described as human beings by the
groups to which we belong
so i am not an individual human named
ben shapiro i am a
jewish white male who is upper income
right that is
that and that's all you need to know
about me you don't need to know my
personal experiences you don't need to
know how i got here
you don't need to know if i've
experienced any discrimination all you
need to know is about those groups
my producer senia is a hispanic female
that's all you need to know about her
you don't need to know
her thoughts her dreams her aspirations
her serial killer record you don't need
to know anything about her
except for the groups to which she
belongs and this is the intersectional
notion it's really vile because again
intersectionality doesn't just suggest
that we can learn
sort of information about you from your
group it suggests that the only
information that is necessary for us to
know about you
is your group information and therefore
we should categorize you as a member of
your group
and if you think differently than other
members of your group it's because
you're not legitimately a member of your
group you've become some sort of
group trader that's the problem with
intersectionality in a nutshell it is
identity politics
it's a responsive identity politics and
so there's this cycle of identity
politics that has occurred
stacey abrams says that we don't
actually need to
be anti-intersectional identity we
should instead encourage
group identification this is the
response to the state of the union
address now president trump is supposed
to give a big unifying address tonight
is he the best proponent of
american unity no i mean i don't think
that president trump has ever unified
anything like legitimately anything
he didn't unify like his business
offices at trump tower so i don't think
he's the most unifying character
and i don't think that that's a huge
shock to anybody
but i also think that the democrats have
made an
actual strategy to divide and conquer
among particular
groups in the united states particularly
split along racial and now class lines
stacey abrams is arguing in favor of
that so here is what
she says in this piece in foreign
affairs she suggests
that intersectionality is a result of
donald trump that is just a lie it is
not true
the reality is that intersectionality
was a theory proposed by kimberly
crenshaw
a solid decade ago and has roots in
the broader social justice movement that
started in the 1960s that divides people
from people by group
and then it was it was promoted by
barack obama in a in a very heavy-handed
way during his presidency
it led to incredible rises in the amount
of discontent along racial lines in the
united states if you look at the polls
what you will see
is that most americans of every race
were moving toward the idea that america
was
post-racial as of 2008 barack obama was
elected suddenly those numbers started
to split again
that is not a surprise i'll explain in a
second why that is like
why exactly america is now more racially
split than it was before barack obama
was president
i'll get into that and then we'll get
into stacey abrams's take on what
american politics
should be and why it's a problem first
let's talk about your second amendment
rights when the founders crafted the
constitution the first thing they did
was make sacred the rights of the
individual to share their ideas without
limitation by that
by their government the second right
they enumerated was the right of the
population to protect that speech and
their own persons
with force you know i really believe in
the second amendment and so do the folks
over at bravo company manufacturing
bcm was started in a garage by a marine
veteran more than two decades ago
to build a professional-grade product
that meets combat standards bcm believes
the same level of protection should be
available to every american
regardless of whether they are a private
citizen or a professional bcm is not a
sporting arms company
they design engineer and manufacture
life-saving equipment they assume every
rifle that leaves their shop will be
used in a life or death situation
by a responsible citizen law enforcement
officer or soldier overseas
every component of a bcm rifle is
hand-assembled and tested by americans
to a life-saving standard
bcm feels a moral responsibility as
americans to provide tools that will not
fail the user when we're not just
talking about a paper target but someone
coming to do you harm
this is why bcm works with leading
instructors of marksmanship from top
levels of america's special operations
forces to learn more about bcm check out
bravocompanymfg.com that's
bravocompanymfg.com you can see their
special offers upcoming news
or check them out at youtube.com bravo
company usa
youtube.com bravo company usa
go check them out right now they're
really great folks so
barack obama in 2008 took office and he
was given this
incredible opportunity to unify
americans he was given this opportunity
to say listen we're all striving to move
in the right direction
my election is proof my overwhelming
election against an american hero john
mccain
is proof that americans want to move
into a post-racial era
and that means that we are we are going
to call out instances of racism where we
see them but we are not going to
spread the label of racism to a bunch of
stuff to which it doesn't apply
instead barack obama knew that his most
solid political path that would have
been
a politically risky path it would have
been because it would have meant
surrendering his greatest advantage in
politics
his race as a way of defending himself
against political attacks
he wasn't willing to do that instead
what he did is he said that every attack
on him was in essence a racial attack
attacks on obamacare
were backed by racism tea party
formation was based on racism
and then every opportunity he could to
stoke the flames of racial conflagration
he did from trayvon martin to michael
brown every time there was any sort
of racial incident in the united states
or incident that had nothing to do with
race in the united states but could be
perceived as racial
barack obama stoked that flame he used
the intersectional identity politics
in order to divide americans so that he
could win re-election and build an
agglomeration of the aggrieved
and you could see this right in 2008
barack obama won not because he
separated americans but because
he said i'm here to unify and then in
2012 running a rough re-election race
against mitt romney he decided more
important to win reelection
than to continue to run under a sort of
unity ticket
because he governed as a very divisive
guy and so because his policies divided
us he instead implied his race divided
us
people bought into that and then the
democratic party began to say things
like well
you know what maybe we don't need white
voters anymore maybe what we really
ought to do is go after this
agglomeration of increasing minority
voters who will eventually be a majority
and those will be the people who rule
the roost and then in 2016
trump ran on the backlash right trump
said okay well
you guys are going to do this routine
where you pander to every minority group
well
i'm going to treat a lot of white folks
as though they are not
in fact as as though they are under
assault
from this viewpoint which is at least
half true
that was part of a part of trump's
campaign so obama started this cycle
and then trump responded to the cycle
and both of that both of those things
are a problem
now democrats are saying well let's
respond in kind let's keep going with
the obama program
here's the deal stacey abrams about to
give the state of the union address
response tonight so
her perspective on intersectionality is
actually a very damaging
perspective okay it is the perspective
that basically suggests that
intersectionality group identity is
inherently good
and useful as a political tool and her
tendency like a lot of democrats is to
blame president trump for identity
politics that president trump
is basing his perspective on sort of a
white identity politics
that is nasty and negative and dangerous
but
the reality is that that identity
politics which i agree i think trump
engaged in in 2016 is actually a
response
to the identity politics in which barack
obama engaged so to understand where we
are with identity politics we have to
start
from the barack obama administration we
have to start back in 2008 when obama
was elected
the american people were extremely
optimistic about race relations in
america
if you look back at the polls they show
that most americans black white brown
everyone thought that race relations
were moving in the right direction
obama was then elected on a particular
basis barack obama was elected
on the basis of uniting americans he ran
a campaign that said we are all
individuals right we're not white
americans we're not black americans
we're all americans there's no red
america there's no blue america there's
just
america that's how he was elected he won
a broad sweeping victory on that
platform
then when he came into office he had the
ability to say
okay now we're going to have an honest
discussion about what's racist and
what's not in america
and i'm not going to pretend that every
policy with which i disagree is steeped
in racism
i'm not going to pretend that the tea
party is racist maybe they just oppose
me based on the size of government
i'm not going to pretend that
republicans who oppose me on the basis
of obamacare
do so because they are vicious racists
because there's no evidence of that
instead barack obama particularly in
2012 decided that he was going to
ramp up racial tensions in order to win
reelection he decided that he was going
to use every racial flashpoint in
america
as a prop for his presidency so when
trayvon martin was shot by george
zimmerman in florida he was going to
come out and say trayvon martin could
have been my son
right he was going to say about michael
brown people in ferguson they're not
just making things up
he was going to do that routine and by
doing that routine he helped divide
americans the response to that
was donald trump so in 2012 obama ran on
this idea that there is this oppressed
group of americans who historically have
been put under the thumb
of the american hierarchy we're going to
unite we're going to sweep back to
victory and it's a proof
that the minorities in america have
finally achieved dominance in america
you saw this in the media a lot the talk
about the
shrinking white majority and how there
was going to be this durable coalition
of minority groups for the future
then in 2016 donald trump ran largely on
the basis of we're not going to stand
for that
and he won and the democrats at that
point had a choice they could have said
listen
this intersectional politics stuff is
dangerous right this stuff where we
divide each other by group instead of
appealing to each other as individuals
it's really dangerous and it's a real
problem
instead they decided we're going to
double down on that we're going to
suggest that in order to fight donald
trump
in order to fight his preferred policies
we're going to call everything that he
believes racist
and all of his voters racist and then we
are going to unify as groups
in order to fight the trumpian agenda
well stacey abrams is
a loud and proud progenitor of this
argument so
she has a piece in foreign affairs
magazine called identity politics
strengthens democracy which is a weird
thing since identity politics from white
people
for most of america's existence was evil
identity politics of white people caused
slavery it caused jim crow
it caused discrimination against gays
jews and asians
right it caught identity politics was
the problem in the united states
identity politics is ex so what's
changed why is it no longer dangerous
well according to stacey abrams identity
politics is different now because of the
identity of the groups
so here is what she suggests she says
francis fukuyama who's written an essay
about why identity politics is dangerous
she says francis fukuyama and other
critics of identity politics contend
that broad categories such as economic
class contain multitudes
and that all attention should focus on
wide constructs rather than the
substrates of inequality but such
arguments fail to acknowledge that some
members of any particular economic class
have advantages not enjoyed by others in
their in their cohort
u.s history abounds with examples of
members of dominant groups abandoning
class solidarity
after concluding that opportunity is a
zero-sum game the oppressed have often
aimed their impotent rage at those too
low on the social scale to even attempt
rebellion
this is particularly true in the
catch-all category known as the working
class so she's pointing at
working-class racism to suggest that now
identity politics
is more important than class solidarity
now my view is that class solidarity is
wrong and identity politics is wrong
i don't feel the solidarity with other
people of my economic class i don't feel
like i have
more morally in common with people who
make the same amount of money that i do
i wasn't making this amount of money
five years ago and i had the same values
so this argument that some working class
white people are bad to working class
black people therefore black people are
a class and white people are
class that doesn't follow it is also
possible that if we treat each other as
individuals we are best off
so she is correct she's not wrong to
suggest that group identity politics
were originally created
by a white majority intent on
marginalizing particular groups that of
course is true
you had a white majority enslaving a
black minority you had a white majority
keeping black people in in dire straits
thanks to jim crow of course that's true
and maybe those groups had to mobilize
in order to fight back against the
dominant white majority
they had to mobilize but they had to
appeal to white people at the same time
they'd use a universal message while
mobilizing as a group
they'd had to do both of those things
but if you are now
suggesting that we are living in a
system that oppresses people as
groups you're gonna need to show
evidence of that it's not just enough to
say
that black people are generally
victimized in the united states in 1960
you could point to jim crow as an actual
legal system
that kept black people under the thumb
of white people
if you can't point to a system that does
that right now then you're going to have
to
abandon your notion that you have to
mobilize as a group to fight back
against another group
right groups form in opposition to other
groups if there is no dominant group
that identifies as a group and that is
attempting to quash your group
your group identity is no longer
threatened so for you to use your group
identity as a baton to wield
against other people is actually an act
of evil
here is what she says she says the
facile advice to focus solely on class
ignores these complex links along
among american notions of race gender
and economics
says my campaign championed reforms to
eliminate police shootings of african
americans
protect the lgbtq community against
arista's religious freedom legislation
expand medicaid to save rural hospitals
and reaffirm that undocumented
immigrants deserve legal protections
i refuse to accept the notion that the
voters must most affected by these
policies would invariably support me
simply because i was a member of a
minority group my campaign built an
unprecedented coalition of people of
color
rural whites suburban dwellers etc etc
and then she talks about
how she lost because she was cheated
basically which is not true
and then she says to seek redress and
inclusion the first step is to identify
the barriers to entry an array of laws
and informal rules to prescribe diminish
and isolate the marginalized
and here is where she gets into her main
point her main point is that
discrimination in the united states is
still done along group lines and this
is a lie that intersectional folks are
going to tell you all the time that
intersectional proponents tell you
we'll get into it in just one second
first let's talk about a great gift that
you can get someone
this valentine's day i'm talking to you
ladies i'm not just this here's
something you can get
for your men this valentine's day i'm
talking of course about
man crates man crates knows what dudes
like to have hundreds of gift options so
you'll know
to find the perfect surprise for him
these gifts are totally unique most gets
shipped in a sealed wooden crate
with a crowbar opening them is an
experience he'll never forget because he
will have to prove
his manliness and strength to you by
breaking into
the man crate they've got unique gifts
like the personalized bar wear crate
with personalized pint glasses and
bottle opener and the pizza grilling
crate with pizza stones and two-sided
dough roller he'll use
all the time i have a couple of man
crates i use the stuff in man crates all
the time i have a whiskey appreciation
crate as you know
i don't drink whiskey except with my
whiskey appreciation crepe because come
on man
it's whiskey and appreciation and a
crate what exactly is wrong with that
man crate has a take on valentine's with
the jerky heart a heart-shaped box full
of beef jerky or the salami bouquet
the name says it all every man crates
comes with a 100
satisfaction guarantee so get him a man
crate plus one of their meaty
valentine's gifts and save
just for valentine's day you get 14 off
when you spend 100
or more at man mancrates.com shapiro
that's 14
off when you spend 100 bucks or more at
man
crates.com shapiro again
that's minecrates.com shapiro go check
it out
and make him prove that he's indeed a
man when he breaks open the man
crate okay so stacy abrams is supposed
to give the response to the state of the
union
tonight and she is very much in favor of
an intersectional politics she thinks
will drive her to victory the problem
for her is it won't okay in georgia the
reason that she came close to winning is
because she appealed to suburban women
white suburban women are not really
turned on by the intersectional notions
that are pushed by people like alexandra
ocasio-cortez
and stacey abrams and tony he see coats
this is not
really what they are thinking when
they're thinking who do i want running
the government
but the case for intersectionality which
again is identification with group
politics
is it's a dangerous case and here she is
making the case she says
the specific methods by which the united
states has excluded women native
americans african-americans
and the lgbtq community from property
ownership educational achievement
and political enfranchisement have
differed so too have the most successful
methods of fighting for inclusion
hence the need for a politics that
respect and reflects the complicated
nature of these identities
and the ways in which they intersect the
basis for sustainable progress is legal
protections grounded in awareness
of how identity has been used to deny
opportunity
and so she suggests for example
anti-abortion rules disproportionately
harm women of color and low-income women
of every ethnicity
affecting their economic capacity and
threatening their very lives this is a
perfect example of how the
intersectional identity is evil
anti-abortion laws are not directed at
minority women
they are not directed at quashing the
hopes and aspirations of minority women
to mobilize minority women against a law
that is not targeting them
by suggesting that their identity is
under threat is an appeal to tribal
politics that is evil by its nature
anti-abortion laws are directed at
protecting the unborn that's all they
are protect
they're aimed at doing that they are not
created by white patriarchies
in order to harm women of color to
mobilize
women of color and suggest to people
that their group is under threat
is to constantly be pressing the red
alarm button in a situation that does
not call for it and to be dividing
americans
on the basis of perceived threat where
no threat exists and when you do that
when you do that often enough
you end up in a very dangerous political
environment
where every political difference is now
grounds
for all forms of resistance up to and
including
in some cases violence if you feel your
identity is threatened
not your politics your identity your
identity as a woman of color is
threatened by an anti-abortion
law you are likely to feel a lot more
passionately about the evil of the
people who are proposing that law than
if you just say well it's a political
disagreement about the nature of life
and when it begins
i mean this is this is why
intersectional identity is dangerous
dangerous stuff and it's funny because
people on the left
used to acknowledge this people on the
left used to acknowledge that identity
politics was bad
when it was the identity politics of
white people but now that it's the
identity politics of groups they hope to
mobilize against the prevailing
hierarchy
then identity politics is good stacey
abrams concludes the current demographic
and social evolution toward diversity in
the united states
has played out alongside a trend for
greater economic and social inequality
these parallel but distinct developments
are inextricably bound together
the entrance of the marginalized into
the workplace the commons and the body
politic
respond reactionary limits on their
legal standing and restrictions meant to
block their complaints and prevent
remedies
okay this is just a lie what she is
suggesting is that as black people have
been more accepted in american society
informal rules have come about to make
them less equal
that's simply not true she's going to
have to point to what exactly
are those informal rules what are those
informal limits if she can point to
limits and rules that actually exist
that we can all fight together
then i'm sure we'll all be on the same
side but if the suggestion is that
as we have become more tolerant we have
also become more unequal because
there are secret nefarious forces at
work in such society
to keep minority groups down then you're
spouting conspiracy theory bull
and that conspiracy theory bull is
dangerous okay it was dangerous when it
was directed against jews historically
it was dangerous when it was directed
against blacks historically
it is dan whenever there is a conspiracy
theory about a particular group of
people
seeking to keep your group of people
down but you can't point to any actual
rule doing it
it's just out there in in the miasma
of politics you're participating in an
extraordinarily dangerous exercise
in polarization of americans along
tribal lines and it really destroys the
nature of america
she says the natural antidote to this
condition is not a retrenchment to
amorphous universal descriptions
devoid of context or nuance so we can't
just appeal to each other as americans
or individuals
instead we have to recognize that we are
inevitably part of groups
and that those groups are our chief mode
of identification
she says americans must thoughtfully
pursue an expanded identity conscious
politics
new vibrant noisy voices represent the
strongest tool to manage the growing
pains of multicultural coexistence
by embracing identity and its prickly
uncomfortable contours americans will mo
will become more likely to grow as one
this is such absolute sheer unmitigated
bull crap i can't even tell you that if
you think that the way to unite
americans
is to say yeah but you're really you're
not really an american you're a black
american you're a hispanic american
you're a jewish american and until we
recognize
your unique identity as these things and
your unique history of victimization
we can't move forward listen i can
acknowledge
the victimization of an enormous number
of groups in american history the
question is what do we do now
and if your idea is that we have to
treat you as a member of a group
rather than as an individual subject to
a creedal identity
you're destroying the very nature of
what was great about america
in the first place okay meanwhile as all
of the state of the union
preparations continue ralph northam in
virginia is in serious serious trouble
so he is going to maintain that job he
is not leaving he says that if he left
right now
then he would be leaving in disgrace
people would think that he's a racist
for the rest of his life so he's just
not going to leave
there is something to this right if you
are a politician your best bet right now
is to double down and never leave
the minute that you show your neck
somebody's going to chop it off
there used to be a sort of agreement in
american politics that if you resigned
in disgrace
you sort of went away and then over time
we warmed to you even richard nixon
he went away in disgrace and then over
time americans kind of went yeah that
was that was
a terrible thing that he did with
watergate but was he really like an evil
nefarious terrible horrible human being
probably not like bill clinton was the
same sort of thing if he had resigned in
1998 he had been a troubled guy
with problems of sex instead he stuck it
out in 1998
and now we have this situation where
politicians are best off sticking it out
because if you can stick it out
then you get to rewrite your legacy
completely right if ted kennedy had done
the right thing
after driving a woman into a river and
leaving her to drown if he'd done the
right thing and just ended his political
career
then he would have lived off his life in
obscurity in the 1970s but he stuck
around
and by sticking around he got to rewrite
his legacy into lion of the senate and
so if you're ralph northam why in the
world would you leave what is the upside
of leaving the answer is there is no
upside
of leaving okay we're going to get into
ralph northam and justin fairfax where
things are going wildly wrong from
lieutenant governor of virginia as well
first reminder you need to subscribe why
well because tonight at long last it's
our episode of backstage state of the
union
you can tell i am so excited about the
state of the union address
i am so excited about the state of the
union address i just
i i can't i can't wait for it i think
it's just going to be spectacular
i just i think it's going to be amazing
okay i just it's gonna be incredible
well while i suffer
with it well you know through it with
you we'll all be there
celebrating it enjoying ourselves
drinking ourselves into oblivion
you can do all these things with daily
wire god king jeremy boring and me and
andrew clavin the ex-girl michael
knowles and alicia krauss we'll all be
here discussing the important issues and
of course answering your questions
will we finally see trump deliver the
state of the union address will he use
the word big
or huge more than 37 times will he
appeal to john miller as the most
victimized man in america who
knows you will tonight as always only
daily wear subscribers get to ask those
questions
so make sure to subscribe today go check
that out right now over at daily we're
9.99 a month get you a subscription also
we do two hours later today
so basically i'm broadcasting all day
all day
to you folks so you need to go subscribe
right now with the annual subscription
a year you also get this the very
greatest in beverage vessels the leftist
here is how to call tumblr
view it cast your eyes upon it it is
indeed magnifique
you will enjoy it little french for you
there it's just it's unbelievable
unreal incredible tremendous endorsed
okay go check it out
right now also subscribe over at youtube
and itunes we have all sorts of great
sunday specials for you and extra
questions and extra segments
just become a subscriber and join the
team you'll really enjoy it we're the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so ralph northam in serious trouble so
now he's trotting out all of his friends
to say that he is not in fact a racist
and it's getting awkward so here is a
childhood friend of ralph northam's one
of his one of his black friends because
this is this is good politics is to say
i have a black friend and then like here
is my black friend so
here is one of his black friends on with
block of wood chris cuomo on cnn
and she is explaining that she believes
that he is not the man
in the picture from his yearbook page of
a man in blackface and another man in a
kkk
outfit at a halloween party or something
she says she believes that it's not him
because she's never seen him be racist
what the governor did
was took ownership of a picture that had
his name
as a prominent heading he took ownership
of uh as the governor he had to he felt
compelled to address that
ralph northam is not the person that is
depicted
in the photograph that's on his page if
if ralph tells me he's not
in that picture i believe him okay well
you know at this point honestly his best
move was to basically say
i don't remember being in that picture
if i was in that picture i apologize it
was
it was a dumb racist and sensitive thing
to do back in 1985 i'm a different
person than that
people who know me know i'm a different
person than that and then he would have
been able to live this out his botching
of the entire situation is what's led to
a lot of the the crisis for him
meanwhile
his lieutenant governor isn't even
hotter water than ralph northam so if
ralph northam did indeed dump the oppo
on his lieutenant governor justin
fairfax about his 2004
sexual assault allegation successful i
mean wow
well played ralph northam if it was you
he says it was not
nonetheless his lieutenant governor is
now blaming the governor of virginia for
dumping oppo
on him about an alleged 2004 sexual
assault
does anybody think it's any coincidence
that on the eve uh
potentially am i being elevated that
that's when this uncorroborated smear
comes out
a year ago uh this was brought up uh you
know and
and yet the posts were investigated for
three months dropped the story did not
do it and they did not do it because it
was uncorroborated and it's
uncollaborated because it's not
true and so it goes away uh for a year
and it crops back up
right at this moment uh you don't have
to be cynical
you don't have to understand politics uh
to understand when someone's trying to
manipulate a process to
uh to harm someone's character without
any basis whatsoever
okay so he's obviously implying that the
virginia governor dumped the apple on
him
then he softened that suggestion he said
he had no indication that northam was
responsible
late on monday night in the same
conversation he then hinted that levar
stoney who's the mayor of richmond
and a potential rival to fairfax for the
2021 democratic nomination for governor
may have played a role he praised the
acumen of a reporter who inquired
whether stoney might have been
responsible and then mr stoney said the
insinuation is 100 natural and frankly
it's offensive so now we have a
three-way
standoff i mean it's the end of the good
the bad and the ugly basically
you have three major democratic figures
in virginia who are all pointing guns at
each other seeing who is going to fire
first
and justin fairfax is just wildly
shooting into the air trying to hit
whomever
here's the reality about the sexual
assault allegation against justin
fairfax it is already eminently more
plausible than christine blasey ford's
allegation against brett kavanaugh
why well because fairfax has
acknowledged that he knows the woman and
had sex with a woman
so right off the bat you have at least
commonality that they went back to a
hotel room what happened in the hotel
room is anybody's guess
now there are no witnesses as to what
happened in the hotel room you have a
basic he said she said scenario from
2004.
does that mean that i believe the woman
no i don't have any evidence to believe
the woman at this point maybe she's
telling the truth maybe she's not i
don't know
you don't know nobody knows but i'll
tell you this there's a lot there are a
lot fewer red flags about her
story than there were about christine
blasey ford's story as it emerged
where she didn't know time place she
didn't know date she didn't know
location
she didn't know any and all the people
she said were at the party said no i
don't remember any of this happening
in this particular case the woman knows
the time she knows the date she knows
the location
he agrees with her about the time date
and location he just says that she
consented and she says that she
did not consent so she has now i mean
this this is getting rich she has now
hired
the law firm for christine blasey ford
she has hired the exact law firm that
christine blasey ford used so we will
see if the media
are as eager in pressing on with the
investigation into the allegations
against justin fairfax as they were
impressing the allegations against brett
kavanaugh that ended ironically with
another yearbook scandal
in which democrats were questioning the
potential justice on the supreme court
about the use of the word boof on a
facebook page from his high school days
so it's amazing you know they say that
history repeats itself first time
as the first time it's tragedy second
time is comedy and
that's fairly accurate i mean brett
kavanaugh that was a tragic situation
for the com
for the country now i think it's fair to
say that we have reached the point of
comedy have you reached the point of
comedy in this whole thing
i think so because we're now going
through every major democratic figure
and finding a scandal a day about them
it is amazing by the way that nobody
found out any of this stuff like where
were the oppo researchers
in virginia i know it's easy for me to
say i wasn't doing the oppo research
still pretty amazing stuff so that is
the latest
from virginia where the democratic party
is is falling
apart i mean frankly they're just
blowing each other up it could provide
an opening for republicans if
republicans could actually take
advantage
and all republicans in virginia have to
do honestly all they have to do is the
same thing that democrats nationally
have to do with trump
not be crazy so we'll see if republicans
can do better in virginia and not being
crazy
than democrats have done nationally and
not being crazy in the not being crazy
sweepstakes democrats are doing
horribly on the national level how
horribly are they doing
well yesterday democrats decided that it
was deeply necessary to
fight against to i promise you fight
against an
anti-infanticide bill i am not kidding
okay so there is a
so senator ben sasse we had him on the
show last friday and yesterday
he introduced a bill to ban infanticide
and democrats voted to stop it he wanted
to bring it up by unanimous consent
and the democrats rejected it they
rejected it what would the bill have
done
it would simply suggest that if a baby
is born alive
you have to use life-saving measures on
the baby you can't just let the baby die
or kill the baby the legislation would
create criminal penalties for doctors
who allow infants to die
rather than providing medical care after
attempting abortion procedures
it mandates that a child born alive in
an abortion clinic be transported to a
hospital
for further care health care
practitioners must report any violations
of the law
the bill institute penalties for
intentionally killing a newborn
including fines and up to five years
imprisonment it would also grant the
woman on whom the abortion has performed
a civil cause of action against the
abortionist and protection from
prosecution
if her child is not cared for after
birth senate democrats
opposed it senate democrats opposed it
so in a second i'm going to
play you senator ben sasse explaining
exactly what happened here and then
we'll get into the
increased radicalism of the democratic
party which just continues the pace
so here is senator sass explaining
that democrats were going to block this
anti-infanticide bill which they
proceeded to do in a few minutes the
united states senate
is going to have an opportunity to
condemn infanticide
100 united states senators are going to
have an opportunity to unanimously say
the most basic thing imaginable and that
is that it's wrong
to kill a little newborn baby
every senator will have the opportunity
to stand for human dignity
to stand for the belief that in this
country all of us are created equal
because if that equality means anything
surely it means
that infanticide is wrong okay well
democrats found that it was not wrong
they say well this wasn't really going
to change the status of the law that is
not true
alexandra de sanctis over in national
review she writes as of 2014
only 26 states had laws creating a
specific affirmative duty
for physicians to provide medical care
to infants born in botched abortions
as of 2016 only six states required that
abortion providers report instances of
infants born alive under such
circumstances
in new york a border life protection was
on the books the recent
abortion expansion from the state
removed it the new virginia bill would
have downgraded the requirement that
doctors provide care to newborn infants
from a must to a shall standard which is
a legally
significant definition so democrats say
that
nothing was actually going to change her
they say it's part of good medicine
to be able to let the baby die diana
green foster a professor of obstruct
of obstetrics recently told the
judiciary committee in the senate that
doctors and nurses and women themselves
know know best whether care would lead
to survival
well maybe not i don't know why women
themselves know what their care would
lead to survival they're not doctors so
that that
in and of itself is pretty insane the
extremism of the democrats continues a
pace ilhan omar who's one of the fresh
faces of the democratic party so fresh
so face tape has now emerged of her from
2013 blaming the united states for the
rise of al qaeda because
she should sit on the house foreign
affairs committee i see no reason why a
woman
who despises israel who is openly
anti-semitic
who blames the united states for the
rise of al qaeda
i don't see any reason why she shouldn't
sit on the house foreign affairs
committee as a democrat
we don't hear the americans apologize
when their troops when their states
destroy other countries when their
states
empire misbehave oversea nobody wants to
face
how the actions
of the other people that are involved in
the world
have contributed to the rise
of um the radicalization
and the you know the rise of terrorist
acts right so it's all the united states
fault that there's been an increase in
terrorist acts the democratic party
doing a wonderful job of painting
themselves into a national
corner my favorite instance of democrats
just
destroying themselves yesterday was was
nancy pelosi i do love
when people in the democratic party
quote the bible it's one of my favorite
things
so here is representative nancy pelosi
an ardent advocate of abortion
speaking about the bible she quotes a
bible verse that in fact does not exist
i can't find it in the bible but i use i
quote it all the time and i keep reading
and reading the bible
i know it's there someplace it's
supposed to be in isaiah but i heard
bishop say
to minister to the needs of god's
creation is an act of worship
to ignore those needs is to dishonor the
god
who made us it's there somewhere in some
words or another
but certainly the spirit of it is there
no
that is not in the bible that's not a
thing
she does quote it apparently all the
time um but that is not
a thing so i don't know what she's
talking about but it is fun to be able
to just pretend things are in the bible
that are not in the bible
and then pretend that there are things
in the bible that don't belong in the
bible it really is fun to watch
democrats selectively quote the bible
while simultaneously cracking down on
religious people across the country
it's one of my favorite things i love it
meanwhile i have to acknowledge
the incredible wonder of andrew cuomo
andrew cuomo is
just a fool and it's hilarious because
democrats who keep saying that we ought
to tax the rich into oblivion
why not a wealth tax why not a 70 top
tax bracket why not
just take all of their money well it
turns out they're trying this in new
york it's a giant giant fail
so governor andrew cuomo on monday
announced a dramatic drop in state
income tax revenue
of 2.8 billion dollars he says it will
prompt him to revise
his 2019-2020 budget and reconsider
spending on schools health care and
repairs to roads and bridges
but why not just raise taxes in new york
governor cuomo i mean aren't there rich
people in new york governor cuomo
i have heard there's an endless pile of
money and that all the rich people in
new york
have giant money bins like scrooge
mcduck and they go swimming in them at
night
can't you just suck those money bins dry
and use it to pay for all the
impoverished in new york governor cuomo
and here was governor cuomo's answer to
that question
he said no we can't do that he said if
we do that all the rich people will
leave
yeah no bleep sherlock i mean we all
know that you idiot
then why are you guys on a national
scale pushing for exactly those kinds of
policies
over and over and over he says at this
point there is no doubt that the budget
we put forward
is not supported by the revenues it's as
serious as a heart attack
and then he suggested that it would be a
horrible idea to raise taxes
on the wealthy again he said there'll be
a very very bad
idea he says we did everything right
from a tax point of view yet somehow all
the rich people continued to leave
how weird how strange
he said that he and his administration
are blameless he said the continued
exodus of residents from the state and a
temporary millionaire's tax created in
2009 to contend with the great recession
but which he has since
extended so it was not temporary that
was not a contributing factor
but he said also god forbid that the
billionaire should leave the state
i do love the the the odd choice that
democrats are forced to make between
tax all the billionaires and we need
billionaires so we can tax them
that's always fun and the democrats
saying we need lots of billionaires so
we can take all their money but also
there shouldn't be a system that allows
billionaires right alexander
ocasio-cortez said that she said there
shouldn't be a system that allows
billionaires that'd be terrible also
we need the billionaires to exist so we
can steal all their money and use it for
our garbage programs
you're gonna have to pick one guys do
you want the rich people to exist so you
can take their money or
do you want to obliterate the rich and
then have no money at all
choose the democrats you know generally
have to make that choice eventually and
that choice eventually is you have to
let the rich people
exist is the reality otherwise all the
rich people leave and
you can redistribute nothing and then
you can see how well that goes
for you okay time for some things i like
and then some things that i hate so
things that i like today okay i do
love love this cnn article it is one of
my favorite cnn articles
of all time the article was it's here's
their tweet
why are adam levine's nipples fine for
air but 2004's wardrobe malfunction made
janet jackson a pariah
for years that's the question some fans
are asking after the super bowl
and here is it's a piece it's a news
piece by aj willingham and brandon
griggs
one of my favorite things is a news
article that says some are asking
so it's basically just an op-ed where
you quote a couple of people
to pretend that it's a news coverage
story they say another super bowl is in
the books and let's just say it was okay
it was adequate
it was a football game that was played
to completion but you know things are
slow when one of the most notable
night plays of the night was a punt the
night wasn't without a few moments that
got people talking here are some
highlights from a mostly somnolent
super bowl super bowl okay they say
people had opinions about adam levine's
nipples
maroon 5's adam levine slowly molted
throughout the halftime show shedding a
jacket
then another jacket and finally a tank
top until he was bare chested in front
of god and big boy and everyone
this didn't sit well with some fans who
wondered why adam levine's nipples were
apparently fine for air while 2004's
nipple gate made janet jackson a pariah
for years
he said the rest of the halftime show
was mostly underwhelming okay so a
couple of notes about adam levine
going shirtless number one you have to
have made some really terrible decisions
in life to have a giant tattoo of the
word california above your belly button
like that that's just a bad decision
like what
why like because you get like you get
drunk
in vermont or something and you end up
shirtless on the side of a road so they
mail you to california
at least you should like tattoo your
home address on your shoulder or
something
then just shove you in a giant box and
send you via stamps.com back to
california
that's that's a solid solid life call
there
adam levine but also i i as i noted
yesterday
you know the number of male fans who
were desperate to see adam levine with
his shirt off
generally i mean males love maroon 5.
they love him
and then they also love adam living with
his shirt off it's just one of their
favorite things but
i do i love it i love the fact that cnn
is bewildered
by why there is a difference between
janet jackson flashing her boob during a
show
and adam levine with his shirt off hint
it's because apples and bananas are not
the same as cnn said that
they call an apple and apple this is not
a banana it's an apple
apples are not bananas and breasts are
not male pectoral muscles
men are not women and they are treated
very differently in terms of sex
they're treated very differently in
terms of attraction and this is this is
so
silly it's so silly but it is indicative
of how stupid
everyone is all together okay time for a
quick thing that i hate
all right thing that i hate today first
of all nancy pelosi and chuck schumer
did a cameo on stephen colbert which is
basically just
the weak democratic national committee
comedy show that's that's that's all
that happens now
so here was stephen colbert at his
supposed super bowl party with gritty
from the philadelphia flyers and patrick
stuart
and then suddenly nancy pelosi and chuck
schumer show up because why the hell not
i mean they have nothing better to do
right
up doorbell
speaker of the house nancy pelosi and
senate democratic leader chuck schumer
please stephen we're friends just call
us chuck
and speaker of the house nancy okay uh
so
what are you guys doing here we figured
your little get-together needed us
uh why why is that because we're the
party leaders
[Music]
well i'm glad you're here won't you come
on in oh no there's more trouble in
washington
we gotta go oh okay use it nancy
oh so much hilarity so much you know the
it's the joshing with the democrats that
really gets me about colbert it's just
all the joshing
you know that they josh together because
you know you don't want like actual
comedy or funny stuff or cutting biting
commentary what you really want
is a little bit of gentle joshing it's
just it's so much fun right guys
so sincere you gotta love it okay final
thing that i hate today so liam neeson
is being ripped up and down
for a piece of audio in which he
explained that a friend of his this must
have been what 30 40 years ago or
something because liam neeson is now 80.
um that some time ago a female friend of
his was raped
and he asked her by whom and the friend
said a black person
and then he had a tribal vicious evil
response
and he explained that and then he says
on the tape that he felt
that it was an act of evil he never
should have thought like this it just
demonstrates
what darkness lies in the human heart
here's a bit of the audio i asked
did she know he was no what color
were they she said it was a black person
i went up and down areas where the cash
hoping i'd be
approached by somebody i'm ashamed to
say that
and i did it for maybe a week hoping
some black
bastard would come out of a pub and have
a go at me about something you know
so that i could kill him
and it was it took me a week maybe a
week and a half to kind of go for that
and she said where are you going so i'm
just going for a walk you know
what's wrong no no no fine
it was horrible horrible when i think
back but i did that
and i've never admitted that dude i'm
sanitated journalist
god forbid
it's awful but i did learn a lesson from
when i eventually thought what the
are you doing you know
okay so the entire moral of the story is
tribal instincts take over sometimes and
they're evil and they're bad and you
have to fight them
so everybody immediately took away the
important lesson of course which is liam
neeson is a racist
so he tells a story about how he did
something terrible back when he was
young and now
he is going to come forward and explain
that those instincts are things that you
have to fight because they're evil and
they're bad and there's a dark side of
humanity and people are like how dare he
tell this story about a bad thing he did
when he was young he never should have
done a bad thing when he was young
okay i think you're missing the point of
redemption i think you're missing the
point of every story about where
somebody did something wrong and then
learn not to be that person
and maybe you ought to rethink how you
think about humans if your first
reaction to that story
is not i'm glad that liam neeson learned
a lesson and can now inform people about
how terrible human nature is
and instead it's i can't believe liam
neeson ever sinned or thought a bad
thing
you know that's you're doing being a
human wrong honestly like how about a
little bit of grace and
particularly grace for people who are
redeeming themselves and and coming
clean about some evil things that they
may have thought or done in the past
if we don't have grace as a society
we're finished alrighty well we will be
here later today with two more hours and
then
we're going to be here covering the
state of the union address which as i've
told you i'm so eager about it i'm gonna
go drink some cyanide now
it's gonna be awesome so if we're there
you should be there too because come on
we'll all suffer through it together
and enjoy ourselves to the utmost see
you then i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
senja villarreal executive producer
jeremy boring
senior producer jonathan haye our
supervising producer is mathis glover
and our technical producer is austin
stevens edited by adam syevitz audio is
mixed by mike caromina hair and makeup
is by jessua olvera production assistant
nick sheehan the ben shapiro show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2019